welcome we want to today's topic on
movin tutorial in this we are going to
talk about the Maven here now we will be
talking about it how exactly we can make
use of me even here in performing
various kind of operations whether it's
a barrel compliation various kind of
stuff there so let's talk about it why
exactly we use maven here now mimin is
something which is a kind of a build
tool which is there for most of the job
is projects here so this tool also helps
us in building up the source code by
downloading some couple of dependencies
these dependencies are something which
is being configured by the developers
which a developer feels that the project
is dependent on and he requires those
dependencies to be downloaded so this
tool is specifically used to build and
manage any kind of a job based project
whatever the complexity of the topic or
the project is there so this tool will
be able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the day-to-day work of a Java
developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities right now maven also helps us
in getting the specific jar files for
each and every project so if you are
going you can pretty much make a jar
file bar file or a file any kind of a
package mechanism you can follow for
your maven there so to download the
dependencies we don't have to actually
go to the official website of each and
every software you can easily get at all
the dependencies of each and every third
party been trace on the MV and
repository comm this is a website which
is present on which if you visit you
will be able to download the
dependencies which is required by your
project or by your specific project over
here so it totally depends on how
exactly you want to download and you
want to get together a specific
repository over here so MV and
repository comm is the one if you visit
you will be able to download and go
through all the jar files dependent jar
files as in dependencies which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so maven is a popular open-source build
tool which is developed by the apache
group and the primary ownership of this
tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once maven is
written in Java and it can be used to
build projects within NC shafts Scala
Ruby etc so apart from Java these are
the different programming languages or
tools which is supported by the maven
here for performing the build activity
so the tool is used for build and
management of any kind of a Java based
project it simplifies the day-to-day
work of a Java developer and helps them
to automate most of the compilation or
build perspective tasks on the projects
right now maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as an
project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process they
take care of all the followings here
builds dependencies reports distribution
releases mailing lists so all these
things are being taken clear as in this
particular process here and ultimately
it's an ability inside the maven that
how the overall build process needs to
be automated and standardized here so
all these curve particular mechanisms is
can be followed as such over here so
that we can have a good the standards
and the simplifications implemented as
such here now what exactly is in maven
repository all about
so mimin repository is something which
is a kind of a directory or it's kind of
a location where we have all the Java
files packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download that
dependent Java files can be downloaded
from there so the metadata refers to the
palme files relevant to each project
here this metadata is what allows me
when to download the dependencies now
there are three type of repositories
from where we can download the
dependencies the first one is the local
repository second one is the remote
repository and the third one is the
central repository so these are the
primary three type of repositories which
is available there for upper specific
maven over here so whatever a repository
you want to follow you want to access
you can pretty much access it and you
can go with that right now
the local repository will be primarily
present on to your PC that's the way
that how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or muadh server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it on to the internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of for dependencies
and the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is safe so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require so
this end repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository its
first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there and central
repository is refers to the momentum
community repository there where you
will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they need it or whenever required all
these are dependencies are cached
locally from where it will be referenced
in the next or you know whenever we want
to refer that we will be able to do that
particular ends easily on that part so
this is the way that how the three
particular repositories or maven
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of auto missions
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
movin here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the XML file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
build up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning washing
information is also stored as such in
this XML file in this particular poem
reference file as such over here the XML
file is which is there in the project
home directory so maven is something
which search for the pom file in the
current directory if it's able to find
that particular pom file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise they it will halt
there itself
so this pom file is very important
because it will act as an kind of a
build script and primary the maven tool
will be able to process each and
everything which is configured as such
in this specific XML file there and
according to that only it will function
or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
Java files so the Java libraries which
we need anantapur into our particular
project so while working on the project
we may be having the dependency on
couple of our dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once these a particular information
or these details our effort so what will
happen that we need to download these
specific dependencies from the
particular maven repositories so if
their dependencies are not present in
your local repository then maven will
try to download it from the central
repository and cache it into your local
repository but first of all it will look
on into the local repository and if it
is not present in local then only it
will go to the remote or the central
repository then we have build life
cycles and phase and goals there so
build life cycles consists of the
sequence of build phases and each filled
phase consists of sequence of goals here
now each goal is responsible for
performing a specific task when our
phase is running all the goals related
to that phase and its plugins are also
used to performing the compilation
preparing the artifacts downloading the
dependencies all different things being
done by the plugins here then we have
the build profiles so build profiles
refers to a set of configuration values
now generally we have the generic build
process for all the environments or the
particular core base there but sometimes
we do have some kind of a difference is
there so that is where we can go for the
profiles because a specific profile can
have its own configuration and whatever
it's required for the build process we
can have different different
configurations stored inside the maven
build script here then we've different
our build profiles are added to the
palme files and which enables the
different build as such here so
depending on these profiles we can
actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build order
missions needs to be performed here then
a build profile helps in consider
maizing the build for the different
environments so that also we can perform
as such while performing or while
working on the different components and
the different management here so a build
profile is
something which can configure you can
utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to decide on that
particular factor so these are something
which we need to take care or we need to
work according to to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here now usually
when we go for the Maven there so we
have to use some couple of maven plugins
now the goal of using these specific
plugins is to automate some of the basic
stuff like compilation creating the VAR
file creating the Java file so when we
are using the plugins we don't have to
configure the steps or write the steps
that how these specific plugins should
be installed or should be referenced
it's ultimately they are internal
configurations which we are looking
forward or which we are using while
working on these specific plugins so you
can download some couple of plugins
using which we will be able to decide at
how the specific goals needs to be
achieved here so maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if we don't want to go for a custom one
so you can do that but pretty much you
can go for the default one and you can
pretty much have some specific goals is
recruited with the help of these build
plugins now next thing is the maven
architecture so in maven what happens
that let's talk about the basic
architecture of Moon here so the maven
is equitable when it's deployed so it
usually reads the permit XML file which
is the build script here now once the
specific bounded external file is being
read out so it will process the
components it will you know download or
it will process the dependencies
plug-ins life cycles phases and goals
and even the build profiles and if any
kind of interaction is required so it
will try to connect to the central
repository or a remote repository and
according to that it will provide the
information and provide the details as
such so moon repository is something
which is very important because it's
ultimately trying to connect to the
maven repository and try to achieve the
various kind of automation here so it's
very important because ultimately it's
trying to help us to go for the complete
end-to-end Bay
Automation when we'd go for a specific
form based build automation so movin is
it will read the power mode XML file
then download the dependence is defined
into the power at the small file and
that dependencies are cached locally
from the remote or the central
repository now then create and generate
a remote report according to the
requirement and execute the lifecycle
phases goals plug-ins extra so it will
process the palm written filed in and
whatever the plugins and goals or the
life cycles which is configured there
step by step each of them will be
executed into a sequence here now let's
talk about the overall build lifecycle
of the Maven here so what happens that
uh the maven build life cycle is
something which is a kind of a
collection of four different steps there
and this is something which is followed
to perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment their second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there so these are
the three building particular life
cycles which is available there at the
Babel level which you can utilize to
perform a various kind of particulars
equation for your project
right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compare is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds though if these are the different
phases and these stages which we
normally follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of benefits the first
one is that Apache maven helps manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation releasing and distribution
in project management here so the tool
simplifies the process of project
building it increases the performance of
the project and the building process all
together and the task of downloading jar
files and other dependencies is also
done automatically we don't have to
indulge in any kind of download part as
such manually over here right and maven
provides easy access to all the required
information so may one makes it easy for
a specific developer to build a project
in the different environment so we don't
have to worry about the environment we
don't have to worry about the
infrastructure nothing is required
everything is available there inside
this package and you know depending on
the particular you can write the source
code on one machine and you can pretty
much do the build on another machine and
this is the reason how the build
automation really happens on the first
place because the developer is writing
the source code in one location and the
same code is deployed on to the
particular or build onto this Jenkins or
any kind of build tool there
right in me when you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the palm file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the specific boundary
XML file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as the chair right so let's
talk about the demo now so let's see
that how exactly we can go for this demo
and we can perform the various kind of
automations so this is the virtual
machine which we have here on which the
maven is already installed so we can run
like NPN so maven will be available as
in three point six point three here now
I'm going to run a particular command
called convene archetype generate here
let me create a directory here our temp
directory and to perform this activity
over there
so MVN archetype shall do it now once we
run that so what will happen that it
will die of some of the by entities
there because ultimately what we are
trying to do is that we are trying to
generate a new project like a maven
project so a couple of particular
plugins will be downloaded by the maven
executable so that it can percieve that
particular execution so we just have to
wait for downloading all these values
now here it's trying to give us a
particular attributes like it's asking
the different attributes over here so
what exactly we want to configure so if
you want to configure you can provide
that details otherwise you can perform
or whatever the setup you want to
perform now here it's asking for the
ocean so which kind of version we want
to follow so I am going to follow like
five here so I will press five then a
group ID which is there so it's
basically a kind of a group mechanism so
I can say like comm dot simply learn so
that's a value which I am providing here
artifact ID I can make it like a sample
project or something like that I can do
so that will be the artifact ID which is
there so version I am keeping the same
only
so
and yeah so package same here so I just
want to create so I will just provide
the value called yes and enter so with
this what will happen that a sample
project will be created here right so
whatever the artifact ID you provided so
according to that the project is created
in this directory so you have to go into
this directory and see that what exactly
the files are created there so you have
the convert XML file now this format x1
file when I open so you can see here
that there are some attributes like you
can have the values related to what
version log group ID you want to follow
so this is the group ID this is the
artifact ID so this is Java file by
default you can change it according to
your requirement then this is the
version and if you feel that you want to
do the changes to the name that also you
can perform here so by default the
j-unit dependency is added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like MV and
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular maven project a bounded
XML file is already there present in the
local directory so according to that the
execution of the steps will be performed
and according to that you will be able
to get some desired values here so
ultimately in the target directory you
will be able to see that some couple of
jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this char file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
an gender equality new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there so that's it for
this demo in which we have find out at
how exactly we can go for a particular
project preparation with the help of mvl
easy key table so that's it for this
demo things right so that was the demo
in which we saw that how exactly we can
go for the maven and we can execute some
build process related to maven there
right so that's it for this specific
topic thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here